what in the Super Mario World as a 90s
Godzilla flick have to do with the new
Mario Brothers movie it's either a giant
land-sized Easter egg or just a goofy
coincidence
the Super Mario Brothers movie keeps
things relatively grounded or at least
as grounded as a story about a pair of
Brooklyn plumbers transported to a
magical land called the Mushroom Kingdom
can be as you'd expect with
family-friendly fare it's a fairly
straightforward Story the evil Bowser
wants to marry Princess Peach and take
over the world so Mario and his new
friends set out to stop him but there
are plenty of wild places for a
follow-up to go in the games Mario has
traveled across the Galaxy explored
strange new lands and even used a
magical cap to mind control the T-Rex
the sky is the limit as far as sequels
are concerned and the movie offers some
hints as to where Mario and Luigi could
go next one of these Clues lies in the
post-credits scene after Mario and his
team have defeated Bowser and saved
Brooklyn and the Mushroom Kingdom the
brothers go about living in this strange
new world but they may not be done with
their old home yet as a scene takes
viewers through the underground before
landing on a green spotted egg that
clearly belongs to none other than
Mario's longtime dinosaur partner Yoshi
it's not the first Yoshi hint to pop up
in the film when Mario Peach and Toad
travel across various lands to reach the
jungle Kingdom they pass a whole herd of
roaming Yoshis however the one in the
egg at the end of the film almost
certainly belongs to the green Yoshi
most closely associated with Mario it's
a clear teaser for Mario eventually
teaming up with Yoshi in the sequel but
not so clear as why the Super Mario
Brothers movie post-credits scene
appears to be referencing 1998's
Godzilla of all films
conclusion of the widely panned flick
after Humanity has defeated the giant
monster the camera guides the viewers
through the ruins of Madison Square
Garden landing at one of Godzilla's eggs
it's hatches and a baby Godzilla emerges
roaring at the screen the Super Mario
Brothers movie post-credits scene is
weirdly similar down to the camera
movements first there's no hatching
however as the screen cuts to Black
Yoshi does admit his signature
high-pitched squeak Yoshi's inclusion at
the end of the Super Mario Brothers
movie could hint to where a sequel could
head Yoshi became Mario's companion in
Super Mario World where Mario and Luigi
go on a vacation to Dinosaur Land with
Princess Toadstool who is of course
kidnapped by Bowser the baby Godzilla
hatching from its egg was actually
supposed to set up a sequel to The
Monster flick in fact 1998's Godzilla
was supposed to set up an entire Trilogy
with the second installment following
that Godzilla growing up and forming an
attachment to Matthew broderick's
character from the first film causing
him to track the creature to the South
Pacific Additionally the baby Godzilla
would have been all grown up with a root
of its own reeking all sorts of Havoc
unfortunately the negative critical
reaction to the first Godzilla made Sony
wary of pursuing a follow-up and it
never materialized hopefully the Super
Mario Brothers movie doesn't have the
same issue while the new Mario movie
received mixed reviews from critics it's
expected to do extremely well at the box
office in fact it's projected to make
roughly 225 million dollars worldwide in
its opening weekend and if the numbers
Hold Steady it shouldn't be long until
Mario is off on another big screen
Adventure this time with the help of his
friendly dinosaur steed